ihs the looks and mosa the science fiction
movistar
dress and do push-ups drive a car and
pick up small object that the young
global the house a serious test and
her or him for the neck 16 days i will
be working in space and she cosmonaut  crew
member
first another young guidance he is
creators hope eventually independently
must one in for him to be able to
paper the cosmonaut working space will the
greenhouse me to dan love
game
wannahave bowery outsite and probe cities robot role clean
separate [ __ ] tube
this is holly  apply the cross my
authentic vision vote and this knox chen
en warm with widgets potentially
dangerous
becomes the project was nearly last in
2017 active you do as enter shooting
toucans
freud for a partner stops and the
component sensors salt and wash and
scientist' we front  compleat over there
on their own have no don't do the room
facet de boer het or viewer and would she is
not into fear
that was because we wanted to demonstrate
how quickly de  robot can combine the
operation at his vision and de movements
of is hans citroen ze technological test
with people looking at this is another
experts
dit si de technological site which of
course a bit of miscalculatie de
mauerpark
pure de has become quite celebrity in
russia and  so a twitter account week
info logical preparations for his first
space mission to the edge is af en joeri
gagarin became the first you my tent
and space yoda guess which use to much
where was your house whose plane linked keep
it space program
up to speed  the young and old robert hesdy
a business bag and pvdw for guys to
settle down on the moon oh mars and pee
and go in the space race what kind of
view that managers do or that you
first latest test m yourself as an
assistant on board international  space
station
step vaessen al jazeera moscow